tell everybody what the or the origin
story is of sumpr why did you
start it so zumpa was uh founded out of
pure frustration with apartment renting
in my 20s uh
i grew up in london moved to new york
with bcg moved to
boston for grad school i think i moved
seven times in my 20s and each time
i thought search was okay you can find
you can use craigslist or zillow or
whatever to search for apartments but
i always found that actually when you
found something you wanted you were
jettisoned into email ping pong with a
property manager or a landlord or a
broker
why was there no e-commerce transaction
for apartment rentals why is there no
book button like there is an airbnb in
short-term rentals for a
long-term lease and so zumpa's founding
mission was make renting an apartment as
easy as booking a hotel and that is
what we're squarely focused on yeah i
mean if you just think about what elon
did
with tesla's the ability to just go
online and order one
and to put 500 and put a deposit like
literally the ford motor company
is in year like how old is it 100 what
years old
and they still can't let you go online
and order a product
i mean this is why these companies are
effed for all eternity
because their whole franchise model is
so disgusting and horrific
and anti-consumer yep but you went
are you able to run this in new york and
places like that where
it's a completely crooked corrupt system
where brokers and i think this may have
changed in the last couple weeks
but where brokers are basically pitting
people against each other and then they
tell you you got to put two months down
but then at the last minute they say
three months and they skim in the third
month
and they high pressure tactics that is
exactly the problem we're fixing when i
moved to new york i could not believe
you're gonna spend a third of your
income on your rent even in york you're
probably gonna spend more than a third
of your income on your rent yeah
biggest transaction you make every year
as a renter 110 million
people in the us rent there's been a
third of their income on their rent in
new york it's even more
and they're being uh kind of duped at
the final step
that is exactly the transparency every
time so
uh in new york for example we work
directly with landlords
when we uh and we do it two ways we
either have could have full server or
soft serve
self-serve yeah some landlords want you
to go do the photography and stuff so we
can send people in we can put a lock box
or actually do a tour ourselves
more than happy to do that some
landlords just want to self serve they
just want to use
our software a bit like how they used to
use airbnb host software to manage their
business collect their rent
zumpa does that for a landlord and so we
offer landlords the ability to kind of
do everything themselves or to get a bit
of help to close stuff
but it was all ideally pointed to the
renter where the renter
will feel like this is an e-commerce
transaction not just a random
piece of paperwork that goes into a pile
which which city did you start with and
why
because this is a regional play yep and
each city is
uniquely different in terms of their
regulation slash corruption slash
how the landlords behave so yeah so i
was in in between my tears hps i came to
san francisco where i met my co-founder
taylor and we started in san francisco
which is a really um we'll probably get
into this warped real estate
city and the dynamics are bizarre but
the fundamentals you can take the words
real estate out of that statement too
it's just a warp city
it is we live in remarkable times in san
francisco it is it is changing very
quickly
um and real estate here is uh unique
very uh strange sixty percent of stuff
rent controlled uh there's some weird
ordinances but the fundamentals are
still here the
landlords need vacancies filled and
they're very worried about like renters
and their quality and so in san
francisco we actually just tested would
renters in 2012
make offers on apartments on an online
board would they just publicly make
offers and
the landlord could then choose between
risk and reward between kind of
how worthy they were and what the price
was and we showed overwhelmingly
landlords would do that and so i think
that was the fundamentals of
this industry will look more like airbnb
that was the mvp
that was just put it up there and just
go ahead and make a bid oh man it was so
ugly as well it was like just
green website like green back pages for
some reason we had everything green i
don't know why it was the worst color
scheme you could ever think oh it was
so terrible on the web awful and you
said the ui was what's green on the web
tell me what's what's a website that's
green on the web so one of our
competitors was green was trulia but it
was i think they've been silly is
a little green it is a little green
splash why is that so purple's
untrustworthy i'm trying to think green
glass doors green they go glass door
green yeah it's terrible next door has a
little green next has a lot of green
yeah
i mean like if you're doing a website
about trail running yeah go ahead and
green but everything else is blue yeah
we ended up
blue and magenta of course so we yeah we
used a really horrible mvp and i
remember at techcrunch disrupt we
pitched it
and i remember the editors of tech
crunches just through before going on
stage we ended up dumbing down
what we pitched because we basically
pitched this off the board where it was
not an auction
at all we did not want to elevate prices
we just wanted everyone to have full
transparency
that if someone had been to that
apartment the night before and made an
offer you knew what it was
the problem was to the outside it could
be misconstrued as an auction
and i remember i think it was alex here
at techcrunch kind of nearly vomited on
us when we uh
pitched it before we went on stage
because she was like this is pretty
controversial it was
actually very good feedback in
retrospect that what we proved was that
everyone wanted to be transactional
online but we hadn't quite
nailed the mechanism in which people did
it yeah whenever you get into an
auction or asking people what it's what
they think it's gonna be
um it just slows things down yep and it
creates
paralysis doesn't it yeah because now
you see four different prices and you're
like okay am i overpaying underpants
this is why like even truecar which i
liked and i'm friends with scott painter
i thought it was a brilliant idea in one
way but it also
uh increases your anxiety because you're
like oh my god there's different prices
for cars am i paying the right price
and now you're getting into this
optimization as opposed to closing yep
that's it and sometimes with
transparency you can engender the wrong
behavior because if you say to a renter
this is not an auction but you're
showing open prices
of course they're going to think it's an
auction and they're going to bid up and
so we ended up doing
something that was the very opposite of
what we were trying to achieve
but we learned something from it so then
we scrapped that literally built a
search platform for four years so the
first four years of zumba had
nothing to do with transactional tools
we built what is now the largest private
company in our space will be used by
kind of 85 million americans
this year to just search for apartments
and now a subset of our listings are
transactional meaning you can kind of
pre-call and book them and our job in
the next few years is just
make a subset of our transactions uh the
majority of our platform